Wow brother with that you better deliver
I am NOT going to waste your time
introducing the one and only Gary
Vaynerchuk there are people in this room
who traveled 24 hours by bus just to see
this man so you better have something
smart to say Gary who cast Gary B is
Gary's fourth business book his fifth
book total his first one about wine
that's where he got his professional
start so I'm hoping you didn't have wine
before getting here you can have an
actor because this is the moment this is
the hour where you are going to learn I
love this word I love the whole focus
here and learn a bit of Gary's genius I
don't get a start because Gary's team
gave me the first question and it's just
so special that I want to share it
genius does not have a timetable when
did yours first manifest Gary you know
are you kidding me it was a sunny day um
in Belarus in a very serious note forget
about the context of that word I think
it was around the time I turned 30 that
I understood that understanding people
and consumer behavior was something that
I had and that there was a way to deploy
it against something besides selling
more wine right and so I'm not
comfortable with the word genius stuff
but this singular thing that I think
will allow me to create a lot of success
in my life is predicated on emotional
intelligence and I started to started to
understand it a little bit more in my
early 30s I actually want to go back to
the word genius though because your
success is based on really really hard
work and grinding it out and there's a
risk out there right now with all of
this enthusiasm and key terms like
disruptive innovation and finding your
genius and being your best self that
there's all this noise that it turns
into a vacuum and we're forgetting you
need to work really hard
card and be good at your job yeah I mean
I I think that we're living through a
period of time right now between shark
tank between you know the social network
the movie that people are confused and
think that it's just so easy to build a
business where you make a million
dollars a year the top 1% earners in
America make $400,000 a year right like
we are not grounded in any level of
practicality right now of what it takes
to be the number one percent executor in
America you make $400,000 a year pre-tax
like like everybody I mean I look at
Instagram all day long and there's
people just spewing how easy it is to
become a millionaire if you just sign up
for my three-course thing or hell you
know it's just unbelievable the lack of
practicality one of the reasons I like
producing the content that I'm producing
now is it's becoming very clear to
people that it takes an enormous amount
of work to be successful on top of which
you actually have to have talent being
good enough to run a business or be an
entrepreneur that has a successful
business is a talent no different than
singing no different than being a
basketball player you're good at singing
I'm atrocious at singing about
basketball I'm terrible at basketball
unfortunately all right and when I say
terrible I put that in the context of
Who I am as an entrepreneur as an
entrepreneur I'm an NBA all-star as a
basketball player
I'm a below-average rec league
basketball player right I could be
working on basketball every day since I
was 12
until you know I was 25 and what I would
be is an above average rec NBA
basketball player this thought that you
if you just tried hard enough or you
work hard enough or you read enough
books or what have you that you can
become this thing that you weren't
naturally gifted with is wrong what you
can be is the best version of yourself
and something no matter how much I
worked on cooking I would not be as good
as Eric in the front row right it just
wouldn't be it just wouldn't be it's
what he's great at it's what he was
gifted at and the work he put in and so
I think the biggest thing the reason the
reason self-awareness is one of the main
things on the book we have to start
understanding what we're good at and
putting our energy against that because
that's where you can start having an
impact whether that is a great
fundraiser for NGOs a stay-at-home dad a
radio person it doesn't matter what it
is but we have gone way too far in the
American Dream of entrepreneurship and
everybody's going to build a
million-dollar [ __ ] business well is
one of the problems the way we're
evaluating entrepreneurship is not about
profitability but it's more about
notability and having your name and face
out there because you go to as many
conferences as I do and it's sort of a
roundup of the same voices over and over
and I wonder well then why are these
people running their businesses are
their businesses making any money well
that look that has a lot to do with the
world that you come from right Bloomberg
knows that if they use those people
they'll get more clicks on our website
they'll get more views on their show so
it's like a self-fulfilling machine
right I mean is it a self-fulfilling
machine or is it a symbol that we're
heading into yet another bubble are we
gonna look back at this moment and say
ah when the bubble burst it was right
there when I asked Gary genius at what
point at when I asked Gary genius when I
asked Gary Vee at what point did you
become a human genius
honestly questions like that make me
think of the year 2000 when we thought
anything with the dot-com at the end was
you know your recipe to be a zillion it
stuff I'll be very frank with you I
really don't give a [ __ ] because let me
tell you let me know that's what I
wanted this I mean look let me give up
but let me tell you what I mean by that
I have no idea if we're in the bubble or
not this that the other thing it's just
not what I think about I think about
executing and doing my thing I've built
two businesses in my life I did them
both during bad times Wine Library
happened right after 9/11 is when I
really started hitting my crescendo I
lost an enormous amount of clients
because they either died or they lost a
lot of money and I navigated my business
through a very difficult time AJ and I
started vaynermedia right when the
financial crisis happened
these companies wanted to spend more
money on marketing let alone something
they never heard of so are we I think
every moments a bubble because I know
I'm gonna win in my craft and that's
just what I think about I don't as an
investor I've been far more conservative
the last 18 24 months because I kind of
had an epiphany 20 month 20 maybe 24
months ago like people were just coming
in and they had no stomach for this they
were good students that you know had
friends and relatives that got them into
a great ecosystem that got them funding
everybody was chasing their next startup
there was no practicality to revenue it
was all about raising the next round and
so look I don't look at startup culture
or entrepreneurship any different than
the stuff that you cover every day Wall
Street and [ __ ] of that nature it's all
the same game there's a ton of stuff
what but it's that it's the same game
right which is I'm not intrigued or it
doesn't seem like an interesting use of
time to debate if something's a bubble
or people like to me it's about
execution I like communicating I put my
stuff out there it's a proxy that
fulfills me I like I like the admiration
I like that my mother complimented me
500 times a day so I need people to come
and do this like I need that I like that
but ever it does your self-worth come
externally yes are you afraid of that
that's a risky place to be no because I
equally have self-worth internalized as
well
I'm that awesome no I'm just that
pulling from opposite directions right
i as much as I want it I don't need it
as much as I you know as much as I
really care what individual people say
on the Amazon on Tuesday somebody's
gonna leave a one-star review on this
book and I'm gonna read it three times
and really internalize it and I'm gonna
really care and I'm really not gonna
care how do you make your money Gary I
make my money in a lot of ways you know
Wine Library is a very successful
business that I built that kicks me
distributions at the end of the year on
its profit vaynermedia is gonna do a
hundred million dollars in revenue this
year and I'm gonna get substantial
distributions from that I'll probably
make several millions of dollars public
speaking
I've got companies that will exit this
year hopefully if the bubble doesn't
burst that will that will that will give
me profit from that I'll probably go
garage saleing on a random day in the
summer and buy some stuff and flip it on
eBay and make a couple thousand bucks
that way how can you be how can you be
your best self doing all those things
I'm guessing if I'm a consumer product
company that works with you yes and I
see all your Instagram is all your
events and all your public speaking look
I would pick up the phone and say Gary I
pay you a [ __ ] ton of money what are you
doing out there promoting yourself you
should be working for me
sure I think it comes in a lot of
different ways first of all I think that
nobody's paying me they're paying
vaynermedia vaynermedia is that's you
know it's not that's what you think you
want to say but it's just not true
vaynermedia is not me I'm Gary baby so
if you left you don't not give a
intermedia wouldn't lose lose clients
vaynermedia will lose clients but not
because of Gary Vee
but because I'm disproportionately the
operating CEO of the company and when
you have a CEO that's great and runs a
business and leaves a business loses
business but that's what I want to get
to I do know that so we have so many
people in this room who are
entrepreneurs yes and or they want to be
entrepreneurs but they have day jobs yes
and they have lots of other commitments
and they look at you and all that you do
and they think I don't even have the
time to compose a tweet
walk me through again how can you be
your best self in all these different
verticals and deliver on every single
one because I'm self aware of what makes
me tick like I need a lot of chaos I'm
the same person that comes to the office
and when everybody's head down and had
headphones on
I'm like can somebody please play music
and make it louder I need chaos it's my
oxygen I need to be doing four or five
six seven things it's when I'm at my
best and stuff really simply like this
is a results-driven business you're a
big girl GE and and GE and Pepsi and
Unilever and J&J they're not overwhelmed
by the garyvee mystique they're
keeping us and renewing us because I'm
clever or because it's fun or because I
Raz or cuz I curse it's because we
deliver I've built a company that is a
machine not me that can deliver on the
KPI for several different reasons first
and foremost Madison Avenue agencies are
not good at what they do in a twenty
sixteen world and there's an enormous
white space we answer it yes sis I'm on
stage why isn't she here why aren't you
here I love you more love you more
so so I'm able to see I want to come she
don't want to come she don't want to
come Eric came 24 hours on a bus from
Sioux Falls as my sister that's my as my
sister would say I know that [ __ ] I
grew up with it um look I think I think
that it comes down to the fact that I
just
outwork most people you know I'm working
on vaynermedia 10 11 hours a day I mean
it's you know that's more than enough by
most standards in the marketplace that
I'm in I when you're working 15 and 16
it gives you time to compose a tweak you
decided about 18 months ago that as hard
as you wanted to work and as committed
as you were you then made a decision
that in order for you to operate at your
best level you had to make health
wellness and fitness a huge priority in
your life that you hadn't before
yes has it changed your performance no
it's made your selfie look better though
yes uh it really hasn't my energy level
is not up I don't feel that different I
feel stronger like when I grab my
suitcase from the you know at seriously
I feel stronger I'm stronger my energy
levels the same Mike and I were talking
about it today my energy levels the same
but maybe when I'm 59 or 72 my energy
level would be different it I it just
became obvious to me that that was a
vulnerability for me and that I needed
to address it and so I did that's
exactly what I want to get to okay for
you you look for vulnerabilities across
your life across your businesses because
you need to narrow the margin of error
if anything you spend a lot of your life
risk managing yes as you look across
your life now where do you see those
vulnerabilities what are you attacking
and addressing because people who are
young don't necessarily think about risk
management they just are grabbing and
going and grabbing and going and they're
not necessarily paying attention to
what's around them you know in business
not a lot to be very honest with you
meaning in the business world I feel
very comfortable that things are going
according to plan I'm sure there's
something going on that I don't see but
right as we sit here
today I don't see a huge vulnerability
I'm doing I'm building a very
conservative business client service
think about what I did set for a second
and I think Gary I think conservative
totally but but you know it's funny I
think I'm stunningly conservative let me
give you the story of this six years ago
at the height of my momentum I'm hanging
out with Mark Zuckerberg and Travis and
sokka and all this stuff I've just made
all these great angel investments right
things are going super well I have a
book that's a year straight on the New
York Times bestselling list with crush
yet I'm getting all these opportunities
everything is going phenomenal I decide
to take a step back and not do a
start-up which I coulda raised 50
million dollars for in a heartbeat not
start a hundred million dollar fund I
stick with me because this is a really
real business and this is what you're
going with this conversation I decide to
build a client service business which is
an 8 times ebody exit business because I
thought the most stable and conservative
thing I could do was to scale the skill
set that I had around marketing and that
I would build a client business and I
got enormous pushback I got made fun of
by all my Silicon Valley friends this
was the golden beginning of the era of
this whole thing and I took a step back
and I built a very boring 19 50 60 70 s
80s but it wasn't very boring because if
you look at consumer product businesses
if you look at fortune 500 companies
they are desperate I'm gonna use this
events word for your genius they
couldn't figure out I don't know about
that I mean every one of my clients
spends 80% 70% of their money on
television print and outdoor media and
not on digital and of the 30% they spend
on digital 80% of that is spent on
horseshit banner ads or pre rolls on
YouTube so they're not so [ __ ]
desperate with their actions they may
say it hold on
yeah but in theory aren't they but when
it goes to practice if you look at any
monster business you could look at
finance media health care whatever they
are those are Titanic size businesses
that don't make good decisions because
they're filled with middle management
who make short-term decisions to
preserve their own jobs be careful not
just middle management the CEOs that yes
it with every single goddamn day ever
morning looking bright and peppy every
[ __ ] morning you sit with CEOs who
make short-term decisions because they
just care about their bonuses and their
stock options in a 12 to 18 month period
yes and the reason they hire you is
because they can point to it and say
digital look I pay Gary all that money
and then they can check it off their
to-do list that's a hundred percent
right so that being the case
who cares if they're making their
digital spend in nonsense they just need
to get to one more day and you I just
need to use that you just need to get
paid by those that's our that's where
you're being confused I do let's take a
step back why do why do I have a nor
media I have a nor media because seven
years ago I decided the best course of
action for me to buy the New York Jets
was to buy brands grow them and flip
them I needed to buy big brands because
that's where the dollars were I knew how
to build fifty or hundred million dollar
business I wanted to buy a business for
200 million dollars and grow it to a
billion dollar business because that 800
million is a nice profit margin and that
gets me on my path right so what I
needed to do was go learn what corporate
America in Fortune 500 companies we're
doing that I didn't understand in
entrepreneur and tech land I don't want
their money staff I want the client that
actually lets me do my [ __ ] if I'm only
able to spend a million or two million
dollars when they're spending 400
million overall I can't move the needle
or understand if my thesis or my
[ __ ] actually works so I don't want
their [ __ ] money I can make more
money speaking than have J&J as a client
I want their permission to reallocate
those dollars to actually drive business
results so I can learn at scale so once
I fully believe I've got it I can go do
it for myself
that's what I need
makes sense right in your experience yes
you work with private companies yes work
with companies that are run by founders
yes work with public companies run by
employees all gamut
it's important I need the context is
there a difference in the way they
conduct their business because those
public companies are forced into
short-term decision-making and the
people who run those companies are
employees not founders do you see a
difference in their behavior yes because
on the reverse so that's bad but on the
reverse so many of the kids in this
audience and in the game right now when
they get funding aren't trying to build
an actual business you know this has
been something I've been ranting on it's
fun that you were skiing this weekend
I've been saying this over and over for
the last 90 days no no but you you are
more than allowed because of the way
you're playing I've people who are
literally about to go out of business
literally in the next hundred eighty
days if they do not raise money they're
out of business that are literally
[ __ ] skiing this weekend are you out
of your mind as an entrepreneur like we
were living from yeah but they're skiing
with their friends that they met at
Burning Man and that's important yeah
and that's exactly and you're and you
and I are both wise enough to know this
that this is exactly what happened in
1998 99 2000 2001 when a lot of these
burning man's were invented and a lot of
those same people who were skiing on the
weekend then had an eight year career
working at Nabisco or NBC or Bain &
McKinsey because when the money runs out
they go and get jobs and that's what's
gonna happen which is quite sad because
the 2016 internet versus a 2001 internet
is very different it is quite practical
to build a business where you can make a
hundred two hundred thousand dollars a
year in today's day and it wasn't in
2000 and so all these entrepreneurs that
are choosing the glitz and the glamour
and the brand of it versus actually
spending time to build a practical
business are gonna be quite they're
gonna be so sad in three years when
they're in the cubicle working for
somebody else realizing they've wasted
that opportunity to build something
practical versus just shooting for the
dream but Gary they're choosing to waste
it yeah you speak to many of these
entrepreneurs and you ask them about
profitability they say well we don't
comment on profitability but can I tell
you who's on my board and can I tell you
how much money I've raised great you've
money because there's so much VC money
in California right now it's coming down
from the sky and sure
loads of people would love to sit on
your board because it's a free option
when are you going to see a shift is it
going to be that unicorns are gonna die
this year that will face them to wake
up's
you know looking you know this world
better and I do you start the first day
of the year in China [ __ ] goes that's
making everybody scared here things have
already tightened up for example in the
angel investing New York tech landscape
the idea of walking into these 10 to 15
firms here in New York and saying here's
my idea I want 4 million dollar
valuation has quickly become I want a
2.5 million dollar valuation right
you're gonna hear about enormous amounts
of down rounds then in a perverse way
you actually like this because for you
this is and only the strong will survive
environment where a few years ago
companies you invested in sure the
valuations were flying through the roof
but now I'm sitting on a vine I'm
sitting on an enormous amount of paper
money on uber Pinterest snapchat I get
out up right nothing would make me
happier than the market completely
collapsing and me going to zero on those
things that's a lie
it's not a lie lanessa lie it's just not
let me tell you why because I truly
first of all my behavior in parallel was
not to completely just invest in that
world you don't want them to go to zero
though I feel as if they deserve to go
to zero based on meritocracy and market
behavior then [ __ ] it let him go to zero
I swear on my children's life yes that
is how I feel now I think that snapchat
and uber and Pinterest won't because I
actually think those are good businesses
but do I think that there is a ton of
unicorns that will be exposed as
rhinoceroses yes I do right and do I
think and do I think on a totally
different level are we is there
thousands of startups that are running
around right now that will quickly go to
zero yes I do and I think that is in my
financial best interest because I've
built a very practical business that
kicks a lot of cash and I'm very
intrigued to take that cash and buy [ __ ]
on a nickel on the dollar as they go to
zero because they couldn't get funding
so maybe on paper I take one step back
but I know exactly what I want to do
during this wartime do you ever wish yes
I'm not gonna say you're gonna say no I
I'm gonna rephrase it we are telling
young people today we are preaching the
merits the joys the beauty of
entrepreneurship and not working for the
man yes and fat-cat corporate America
yes but are there lessons to be learned
working for corporate America is there a
big positive and maybe are we repainting
too negative a picture of what it looks
like when I finish school I never asked
myself should I go work for the man I
simply said god I thought there's a guy
out there who will hire me yeah so I've
gone too far doing a disservice to you
like man I think we've gone too far in
pockets look let's look at the big data
the big data overall is not that many
people are still starting their own
companies there's unlimited amount of
kids that can't wait this may to go work
for the [ __ ] man there's plenty of
prac what I think we've done is we've
told two to four million individuals who
should have gone and worked for the man
because they would have gotten a lot of
value out of it and skills and learnings
and stability that they too should be an
entrepreneur and that's where we got a
little too far in our little bubble and
by the way that's their fault right like
like that's you not being self-aware or
auditing your own skills that's you
hoping and wishing that you can build
the next Facebook and that's my fault
for writing you a check I had a meeting
with a kid the other day who's going on
a business did that was the meeting the
meeting was hey man I'm going out of
business and like can you help me with
some other stuff and we're going through
the meeting and this is a kid that I
rode $150,000 check into his business
and he's like going out of business and
he goes you know and I'm sitting I'm
concerned not a good face because like
you know I invested and he lost and he
goes Gary don't worry man like he's like
touches yours don't worry man I learned
a lot
and I said I'm not worried about that
[ __ ] you lost 150,000 of my dollars
I'm like and so we what I'm most worried
about Steph my stutter is here
I'm sorry well don't bring your daughter
next time so I think look like I mean
are you really confused of what I was
gonna say up here I mean I think I've
branded myself quite nicely - no I just
think [ __ ] is pushing it you know so
I look I think I think that I was
stunned I say it's theft stay with me
here all right price I was like okay so
I was like this is insane this kid
literally thinks that I'm worried about
what he learned or didn't work we've
completely gone into bizarre oh yeah but
we've done that to him Gary
that's great listen I don't think I've
done [ __ ] to anybody I and you guys know
this a lot of you were here you know my
spiel this is why I've been talking a
lot about on dailyvee which is this is
how I roll this is what I do I'm not
telling you you have to work 18 hours a
day you could be on the softball team
I'm not telling you that you have to
reply to everybody you don't have to I'm
telling you this is what I do so that
there's no confusion that for me
that the level of talent that I have
that outrageous all-time work ethic is
part of the equation you're more than
welcome to think that's interesting not
interesting I've noticed so that's so he
said Gary I learned a lot I got pissed
and I'm like the other thing I got mad
about was like I'm like kid and I
shipped it I got mad and I say listen
you have a problem here you thought this
was a smart move easy money you'll learn
better than getting a job I can always
get a job well you don't realize is the
email chain that's gonna happen when you
walk out of here with me and Dave Morin
and Chris Sacca and first round capital
and we're all gonna be like loser loser
loser and you can't actually get a job
no no he'll get a job but it's gonna be
really hard to raise money again from
the people that he actually wants to
raise money from like our reputation
matters like taking a loss is real and
there's this whole kind of feeling in
that space that it's not why does he
have to raise money again why is why
does
entrepreneurship is it's easier looking
expect that's like what why does
entrepreneurship half does a career why
is it now taboo to say I'm gonna get a
job I'm gonna say it one more time
97% of people say that exact thing so
you're living in a New York bubble where
you're me but we're not celebrating
those people I agree there's a thing I
did on Bloomberg before you were on
bloob like years ago it was a TechStars
were you a Bloomberg wouldn't they did
that okay techstars did a show where
they were where they had four say it was
around techstars on Bloomberg where they
were following eight startups it was
like the last episode is like a real
world event right there was people
sitting there and talking about like you
know what happened on the show you know
how real world usually the wrap-up show
that's what they were doing seven show
so I'm there with five other VCS seven
companies going to go hi I'm Rick and we
created donkey donkey calm and we raised
four million dollars and everybody
clapped right and he would sit down hi
I'm Stan we created like luffy luffy org
and we've raised seven million dollars
and he would sit down and everybody
clapped finally this kid gets up and he
goes hey we're from Red Rover we didn't
raise any money we got a couple clients
out of the exposure and we didn't raise
any money and we're just kind of start
again going silence I lost my [ __ ] on TV
shocking you know I was like this is why
this is all gonna be [ __ ] right
because literally everybody just stood
up and said hi I'm Johnny from boogy
boogy boogy and I gave away 30% of my
company and we clap up these guys
actually built a business and nobody can
back it up please
right there for aspiring entrepreneurs
yes when we say I raised four million
dollars I raised 1 million dollars that
means I gave away X percentage of my
business do you believe that budding
entrepreneurs realize what the
implications of raising money actually
means 96% no it's a bummer
I think most people don't get it I think
it was very attractive you're young
you're gonna build the next Facebook and
let's go okay and that's what happens
Nikhil Jin right there yes you're young
yes
well what do we say I'm 40 so you does
being an entrepreneurial genius is that
only for people under the age of 35 what
if you are 40 50 60 or 70 this whole
entrepreneurship game isn't in it for
you because we keep using the word
you're young you're young well what if
you're not young yeah I mean a couple
things on that front it's funny you said
that it's something I've been spending
some time thinking a lot about number
one you know if you're at 35 40 you know
45 and you've worked as a non
entrepreneur you're not an entrepreneur
first of all I think anybody and you
couldn't be you sure can be you're more
than welcome to be but you're not a pure
bright entrepreneur listen this is
something a lot of you guys know that I
get razzed on online because I say that
if you ever work for anybody else you're
not an entrepreneur because my
definition of an entrepreneur is you
can't breathe at the thought of working
for somebody else that's my my personal
my personal point of view on being a
true bred entrepreneur if you're if you
are a true entrepreneur the notion of
working for somebody else is so
devastating that you would rather live
on a couch with your four buddies with
[ __ ] cockroaches and eat [ __ ] food
everyday to try to build something I
truly believe that what about the
argument that we're all entrepreneurs
and I could say 70 ruled Bloomberg media
I work for myself and if you behind a
shelf and if you respect
but why why including cuz somebody pays
your paycheck yes that's just Google
[ __ ] entrepreneurship that's not what
it says so why can't ask why can't one
take an entrepreneurship approach to
their own they can they can so again a
lot of people that follow me know that
the way I decipher from an entrepreneur
is I use the term entrepreneurial
tendencies I think you have them
you've been very smart in my opinion
from afar - I like you it's why I want
you be here tonight first of all I knew
it wouldn't be I mean some of them are
probably confused beginning I knew it
wasn't gonna be a cush interview right I
said everything but it was gonna be the
normal like carry weight was it gonna be
when did your genius first America
that's right the guy's run during that's
right and so that was interesting for me
and so but more importantly I do think
we can have entrepreneurial tendencies I
think that's great and I do think that
people need to be practical
I do think if you're sitting in this
crowd right now and you've dead if
you're from college right or if you have
I mean look do you know many people are
dealing with real life stuff included
stuff like that nobody ever talks about
including like I sit up here and be like
be an entrepreneur and meanwhile you're
sitting in that audience and saying my
spouse died my [ __ ] spouse died like
my spouse died I've got two young kids
like it's not so easy to be
entrepreneurial and there's real stuff
that happens in people's real lives
here's what I'm saying we are living
through the luckiest period of time ever
for all of us because there's something
called the Internet when your spouse
died in 1972 right
you had no practicality after 7 or 8 or
9 p.m. when you got home to change your
life you're just kind of like came home
the world shut down right you got rest
it's probably what you did or maybe if
you were really hustling you got an
overnight grave ship job right but now
we have the Internet
the practicality of turning your life
into an entrepreneurial is very real
from 9 p.m. on till 2:00 in the morning
every day
everybody here is more than welcome for
five full hours a day which oh by the
way is about the amount of time that
most people actually work in their nine
hour day because these [ __ ] [ __ ]
our lunches and the 20 minutes that you
watch some random video on YouTube that
your buddy sent you and you're texting
all day I mean
you're watching askgaryvee that's your
damn right you're damn right I mean
people are really in these jobs
deploying only five or six hours right
and so there's so much time to do your
thing
the problem is people say things and
then do different things we say things
we say that Sam maybe that's what we
like and on Amazon they know what we
bought correct that's a nice point good
one to sneak in their step I think that
we I think more importantly you don't
pay me to be here you're gonna need to
be nicer I'm being very nice we say
things like if Trump wins I'm moving to
Canada and then we don't right yeah we
say things we say things like we say all
these things that go against our we say
we give a [ __ ] about privacy and you're
giving away your data all the time 24/7
365 so I play in a white space of what
people say we say that I'll never be on
snapchat it's so stupid
we say things and then I've spent a
career trying to figure out what we say
versus what I think is eventually gonna
happen and then I bet my energy time and
money on that give me an example
Facebook everybody said the Facebook was
just for kids
people forget Facebook ecommerce let me
start with my first career ecommerce I
was a 22 year old kid and everybody told
me directly in my face
Gary you're an idiot go open a second
liquor store nobody's gonna buy wine on
the Internet the internet is a fad who
are those people
yeah I don't know your contemporaries
there they were on The Today Show
saying that the internet was a fad every
single [ __ ] day Wow and listen all
the 40 50 60 year-olds remember there's
if you're a 50 year old and you're 60
enroll here you remember your first
encounter with the Internet I'll give
you one forward
everybody in this room in 20 years is
gonna live in a virtual reality world
where they're gonna have a tough time
even quantifying the difference between
is this real life or is virtual real
life when I said that right now as
people are thinking about what I just
said they're like yeah we'll always you
know as I've been talking about this
with people they're like we're always
gonna be needing each other of course
but if you don't pay attention to how
people living their lives out there
tonight where they're looking at their
phone even though they're in the Y
we're already living our lives in a
virtual world while we're in a physical
manifestation right like we're already
doing it and so I think there's I think
my whole life has been that from EECOM
to email marketing why don't you do
catalogs instead it's better
what's email to the YouTube show I
started that's so stupid who's gonna
watch YouTube older people aren't gonna
watch that it's just gonna be kids
Facebook's just gonna be for kids right
so my whole career has been that then
what did you do that didn't work the
things that I've done that haven't
worked have been more predicated on me
thinking I could run multiple businesses
at a time let me explain
I'm only running one business right now
what is that vaynermedia right I'm
working I do content for my personal
brand I invest right but I'm not
actively running the business in 2009
when I started vaynermedia I also
started another web show called obsessed
TV I started a social Y network called
quirked what happened and I split I'm
not done yet and I started another and I
started another social network for
designers and developers called Forest
I had a managing partner in all three of
those businesses but I was relied upon
to do my part right to thought whether
it's money whether it's marketing
whatever it may be what happened was
they all failed because I was over
promising what I was going to be able to
deliver for that business out of having
big eyes I can work 18 hours a day but I
can't operate more than one actual
business at a time and that's a struggle
for me and it's one that I feel like I'm
getting caught in all the time I
secretly think I can do it again now
even though I know I can't it I'm very
drawn to it but it is a vulnerability I
get big eyes you are drawn to bright
lights and big ideas and you follow them
yes there's only a few things we really
can't control in the world
right they control our health can't
control the weather we can't control
time yes
you cannot affect them you can't get
them back right is there anything you
are afraid of that you could look back
and say I didn't I know I'm racing I
know I need to keep going towards this
shining light yes I think it's the right
thing but there have to be
things that you're not tending to and in
the dark of the night at 2:01 a.m. just
go to sleep what are you afraid that
you're missing that I'm tricking myself
that I'm running the right pattern of
work-life balance
Gary overachievers don't never had
balance so why do we even use that term
I'm using it to context the conversation
but I'm guessing you were never balanced
and then people who keep getting at no
but it's true whenever yeah but deeper
success with your alas about work like
that it's a mistake I never bound mine
but I you know I can't speak for others
but I can tell you easily one of the
biggest regrets of my life are the first
five years of my marriage not taking two
to three extra weeks of vacation with
Lizzy easily one of the no question work
and I've almost no regrets I regret not
hooking up with more chicks in my 20s
because I worked every minute and I
regret not not spending 20 days a year
with Lizzy before we had kids when I
easily could have and so I think about
that in the time that I spend with my
kids now and what how do you that so
what it so I do the best I can I do what
my heart tells me I just don't know you
didn't fix the whole thing what the hell
thing which is a little more public to
everybody I didn't hear what you said
before the but repeat in a second before
the health thing three or four or five
years ago I started taking seven weeks
vacation or three years ago for you to
take seven weeks vacation I do I do when
you're on making instead of two and so
hold on when you're let me just finish
this thought so that's a hack right one
thing that I'm talking about right now
quite a bit and I'm a very I don't know
how you guys roll I'm a very where
there's smoke there's fire kind of guy I
like literally selling myself I'm
talking a lot and I mean a lot about the
idea of coming home every day now from
five to six and eating dinner with the
kids or giving them a bath and then
going back out and I haven't done it yet
and I'm talking about it the same way I
did with my health for about a year
before I pulled it off but I think I'll
do that and so all I can do stuff is try
and and just try if it's on my mind to
hack it and make it better when you're
taking those seven weeks of vacation a
year do you disconnect I would say 80%
of the times or of the time
I've been able to I was I've done a
really good job and so I was wrote like
yes but once in a blue moon something
bad will happen
aka this last year I did really well
until I read a quick little thing on
some of the data I was looking at around
snapchat until I'm like DJ Khaled is
starting to get momentum on this
snapchat thing also as his wind that's
right and so and so and so for the 17 or
14 day vacation I took at the end of the
year the first eleven days were really
good and the last three were really bad
because I caught the snapchat bug and I
shifted it's just the truth are you
being honest with yourself about do you
disconnect if we asked Lizzy yeah she's
here well [ __ ] I just told you that I
[ __ ] rolled the first 11 days but the
last three days I [ __ ] up so it's not
like I just said yeah I'm cruisin so if
you wanna do you want to ask her if it
was 67% of than 80 all right we have to
share some audience questions you ready
always what is the number one timeless
lesson you learned and carried forward
from selling sports cards as a teenager
from Roger Roger good question um not
Goodell I uh I start I learned that
attention was the only asset one more
time
I learned this is straight up this is
why I think I was a good retailer
because of baseball cards I learned that
attention was the only asset that
mattered so I would go into baseball
card shows and I was 14 years old like
Dino junk that is like and the dealer
would be like a 40 [ __ ] year old man
right like you yes and he would be like
hey kid that's your table and the first
five or six shows I ever did I had the
shittiest table in the whole mall like
the side entrance over here when the
whole main thing and I kind of like by
the fifth or sixth one said wait a
minute this is bad like because when I
go take go get a pretzel there seems to
be more people over here than that are
over by me and so there's a classic
story I have with Brandon who runs Wine
Library it was my best friend in high
school we did shows together where it
was the show and we get this table and I
go Brandon like there was this whole
main thing and we have this random table
on the way out and I'm like Brandon this
is bad we need a different table we got
like I was really fun
say look I'm gonna go he's like no no
this is super fine just like it is
literally the first guy that came into
the show like 8 o'clock in the morning
walked the whole show bought a ton of
[ __ ] and on his way out he looks at us
and he goes oh [ __ ] I didn't even know
you guys were here and there was
something about that moment that
triggered for me and what I did on every
show when I negotiated forward was
picked the table I've gone Thursday
negotiated my table before I'd even pay
the guy and what it did was it taught me
about consumer behavior how they walked
around and when I got into my dad's
store I started reorganizing shelving
based on profit margin and things that
later I would learn is really common
practice of great retailers and that
came intuitively and that was absolutely
taught to me through intuition but also
through behavioral stuff at baseball
card shows seeing the you understand
retail you know what a great retailer is
you know what iconic brands are are
there any brands out there that you look
at and say oh that is an iconic brand
that means that has meant so much in
history but today means nothing I'd love
to get my hands on it Nintendo why cuz
they're [ __ ] up like there's no 15
year old like the fact that Nintendo is
not winning in-app gaming is ludicrous
they have the IP the fact that
Kardashian apps and like and like and
minecraft and other things are winning
while while there isn't a 15 year old
that gives a crap anymore about Mario or
Zelda or things of that nature that was
a huge miss and they got romantic that
it was all about the council where they
made their money right and they were
romantic and they didn't deploy against
the next attention police and they
allowed that romance to kill them people
think the end of your story is buying
the New York Jets yes you buy the Jets
yes then what then they make a big
[ __ ] movie about my life
well there you go how would you define
emotional intelligence I think it's the
things that are actually happening in
our world I think it's the things that
are happening that we can't explain this
of course we can
like charisma matters right like like
intuition matters like deploying empathy
and gratitude matter these are real
things that's why they exist that's why
they're words they're real things and so
I would define them as the all the
things that aren't about black and white
either data or math or written words or
information that really separate people
from success or not I consider it
likeability is a good word I think
likeability is a very you know
likeability is completely predicated on
emotional intelligence right and so I
think it's I actually think because
information is becoming commoditized by
the internet it's never been I actually
think I'm a complete byproduct of the
internet becoming important because I
think I so over sku in emotional
intelligence and under skew in you know
IQ that um I think I'm a preview of
things to come do you think we've become
too reliant then on big data big you
know the fact that we talk so much about
it it sort of takes out the element of
surprise you know I take you to the NBA
Mark Cuban would say implementing big
data is the key to having a winning team
and at the NBA a tech conference Charles
Barkley and Magic Johnson sat there
Charles Barkley said big data big data
you know when a boy has basketball
skills forget big data so what's the
right lane booth it's just both right
like I love big data but do you know
where my success in vaynermedia's for
their client success comes from with big
data having the human ability to
interpret it and turn it into something
and talent Trump's all what Barclays
argument is and Barclays very right in a
lot of areas and a little bit wrong in
some other areas in my opinion I know
his argument on this which is look
talents gonna trump anything if like
basketball especially like look who's
won the NBA title for the last thirty
years it's been like the eleven guys
right like like in basketball one player
unlike any other sport fundamentally
dictates the
because they play they play both ways
not like football baseball right they
it's just clear right that being said
you can maximize you can maximize that's
it and you can maximize getting a role
player who hits corner threes because
that's the highest percentage and so the
Spurs have used that the Rockets have
used that like to win more games so it's
both what's the number one thing you
want everyone in this room to walk away
with and this question comes from Alana
McMillan everywhere that I think there's
literally 300 million different ways to
win in the u.s. if that's how many
people we have right like that there is
no blueprint there is no exact way it
only comes down to being able to factor
in the 40 or 50 indexes input points
context points around your life and then
navigating through that and so what what
I really want is for people to
understand don't do it like me don't do
it like you don't do it like sucks don't
do it like traps don't do like Kuban
like spend as much time as you can and
stuff I'll be honest with maybe you know
the answer I'm actually weirdly asking
you if I knew how to help people like
create more self-awareness it's what I
would sell I don't know if that becomes
your therapy or some system or I don't
know I really don't my fear is actually
the reverse in terms of with all of the
information with all the self-help with
all the people on Instagram saying these
three easy steps
the fear is we are telling people as
soon as you have a job that you if you
have a job that you like click and when
you meet a man that you like click and
then you could afford a house and then
you have a baby all of these things are
the recipe for success well if you're
using some sort of Cosmo checklist for
the recipe for success you are going to
end up very unhappy because success is
internal so I'll go a different way find
but I actually think we're in a much
better place than we've been for the
last 60 years on this issue I because
prior to this world where we have so
many more opinions and platforms we had
three channels that told everybody that
thing there was three old white guys
that owned ABC and NBC and a great point
that completely pushed down to them what
it was supposed to be so now at least we
have a lot more voices and there's more
things to navigate thank you one thing I
look at when I look at your
career Gary listen I get excited when
you say that's a good point because I
know how you roll and no I think it's a
really boy I don't it's a really good
point three people said this is the
American Way
woman you stay at home man you do this
everybody go work for the Machine
because that was an invested interest of
all the people on the top and so now at
least they have more options now I'm
your American dream you know now look
there's a lot of bad from that because
there's a lot of [ __ ] hucksters that
are selling you guys [ __ ] that would
have never gotten on TV that you now are
listening to because you know they're
renting a $300,000 car for the day
taking an Instagram photo of it and
saying yo you know it's sitting folks
that's not but hold on yeah but it's not
those hucksters fault so everyone in the
audience who complains that the
Kardashians were on magazine covers a
hundred and ten times last year it's the
it's not the mental dot but it's not the
Kardashians it's all more colorful it's
not the media's fault Media will sell
whatever you will want reverse a problem
if you don't like it stop buying a
hundred percent more importantly stop
judging other people's escapism like I
don't care if you like the car good for
you
I like the Jets that could be a waste of
five hours a day it's grown like like I
don't on a second if we asked Lizzie
it's way more than five so it's probably
right yeah I mean look the fact of the
matter is is that everybody needs
escapism everybody needs it it's a it's
what music and entertainment and
everything is built on so I think we're
wasting too much time judging people's
choice of escapism I'm saying don't
listen to these hucksters because I
think I'm gonna be played out to be
right because I know what their
intentions are I know them they're not
doing the right thing but I'll be very
blunt with the 600 people in here I
don't care if you do it I can't I can't
I don't have enough time or energy in
the day to individually care if you
figure it out that there is no quick fix
in building something that puts you in
the top 1% of society that's a fear
though Gary that's the risk we'll
stopping you Derek who are rushing to
say Gary solve my problem I haven't ever
done business I have it every day I'm
very comfortable in that environment I
give answers every day to that and I'll
decide what I want to do on an
individual basis and if I lose then I
deserve to lose
if they lose they deserve to lose I am
an absolute believer that the market is
the market is the market is the market
and so you can trick the market for a
few minutes and you we can be upset
about all the fake entrepreneurs and the
funded companies but don't be a day that
comes and then they'll be gone and it'll
be [ __ ] awesome and it'll be awesome
I'll tell you why because that's what's
supposed to happen guys nothing good
comes easy like what good stuff should
come easy like like I use this word
audacity if you mean the audacity to be
in the 1% which one more time means you
were making $400,000 a year before taxes
which is by the way a booby prize to
most people when they think about
entrepreneurship I don't know anybody in
entrepreneur tech land or entrepreneur
solo entrepreneur that thinks that 400
thousand a year is the North Star it's
much bigger than that I get the emails
every day everybody thinks a million
year is like the minimum cost of entry
to anything right
ok bow Gary yeah someone always has to
pay this whole idea that you know I'm
gonna build a multi-million dollar
business I want everyone to get free
pre-k there is no light at there is no
gold at the end of the rainbow someone
has to pay ok so this idea that oh well
no one no one thinks $400,000 is a lot
of money when are we gonna click and
realize oh [ __ ] it is you members it our
whole entire human race from the
beginning of mankind has proven we will
never do that it's just not a human way
like and that's fine there's nothing
wrong with like great like we you know
what by the way I'm the biggest fan of
humans we're still here like I actually
think I actually think humans are the
most underrated brand in the world I
actually believe that what does that
mean I'll explain
I'll explain I think humans I'll tell
you underrated by the world that you
live in yeah big media has done a really
good job in convincing every mother in
here that they shouldn't let their kids
play outside because they [ __ ]
reported on kidnapping until they
couldn't get enough of it right and so
now we have a generation of people that
don't want to put their kids outside yet
we're safer than ever because of devices
nobody's kidnapping anybody yet
the propaganda filled us nice and good
right and so what does it mean I mean
humans could do anything to each other
we should have blew each other up a long
time ago with the atomic bomb we can do
I I could stab you in the face with this
fork right now right like that I'm not
screaming on MSNBC and so but think
about this think about think about how
much damage we're capable of to each
other we do so little the problem is
mainstream media reports on that point
zero one percent I really believe that I
really think I really am a big believer
now I'm stunned how good people are I
love it okay but here's the great part
good mainstream media reports on that
yes is it's sort of the way the system
works but the beauty of social media the
beauty of the fact that there are more
outlets today than ever there are no
longer three networks telling you this
is the news today now your news creator
your content creator that's the beauty
of it so the criticism that you have is
valid but the barriers of entry have
gotten so low that anyone in the room
can decide this is what the narrative
it's gonna be Arianna Huffington's good
news vertical is the biggest moneymaker
she has within the huffington post it's
about making a decision you talk about
Unilever at CEOs like Paul Pullman who
make a decision to say no I'm gonna be
good in front
I told alia gree with you I think when I
believe and look I actually have a more
optimistic view on this
I actually think once we wrap our head
about privacy we're about to go through
a real unbelievable here I think I'm
gonna missin me I think once we go
through a full cycle I think 80 years
from today humans are gonna live a much
happier live life than we do now because
they'll be less privacy I think once we
all wrap our heads around I think I live
a stick with me I think I live a happier
life and I'm a better
man because I know a lot of people are
watching me and it's changed my behavior
and so I'm optimistic why are we doing
before nothing but I mean you just open
it okay my Hatter's loss come on babe
mine Alex Melissa's brother-in-law Liz's
brother my brother-in-law had a wedding
we went to Vegas and I decided not to go
to the Spearmint Rhino because I was
exploding on Twitter at the time and I
thought it would be a bad idea of
something else a picture no it's
Spearmint Rhino is it's the most
well-known gentlemen's club just off the
Las Vegas Strip right so like just
little things like that like I love that
up like you know like I you know I I
just truly believe that when you're
living your life had you not been
blowing up in social media
you'd have been front and center and no
$1 bill that's right yes and and and and
and more poorly not that that's bad but
I'm watching a lot of people's behavior
shift and look who decides what's good
and bad and you can get into very big
arguments but I'm telling you right now
when you wrap your head around knowing
that everything you write and everything
you do is searchable your whole world
changes if I told all my homies right
now hey bro every single thing you send
to a girl on tinder eventually be
searchable under your name I think some
of the [ __ ] they'd write would be
different okay all right that kid that's
a perfect perfect segue Gary yes if you
were 22 to 32 in 2016
how would you document your journey as
an entrepreneur would you show
everything the ups and the downs
especially so the so this comes from
something that I've been talking about
which is too many people are posing as
like um are crippled by two things one
they don't want to put out content
because they don't think they've made it
yet and they don't deserve to which is
something I believe in
so like when I say to you Gary I don't
think that picture was very flattering
of you I would I don't think you should
have posted it no that doesn't bother
but like really like I mean people
saying things like you know I don't know
if you know this stuff but there's a lot
of people that want to be twenty
two-year-old life coaches
right you actually okay yeah so I find
that intriguing you know and so and so I
feel I'm going to help some of them and
say look you that's a bad place to go
because no normal person thinks that
you're a true like life coach at 22 but
I tell them I tell them look you could
be talking about your experience as a 22
year old looking at the world and you
can bring value to other people
cuz you see the world differently than a
45 year old so that question is
predicated on something I believe which
is how cool would it be right now if you
wanted to you could go to youtube and
watch how Vera Wang learned to become a
dressmaker if she was producing like
this was my first day at the internship
at NASA you know whatever play like so I
think everybody's truth has the
potential to be interesting especially
if they've got the chops okay but here's
the scary part okay when people put
themselves out there like that what if
no one cares what if it hold on it's a
great question
what if no one cares what if no one
follows them what if no one likes them
they should be right yeah that's a
really hard place to be to truly put
yourself out there and say Here I am
world I'm starting a gym it's the first
day I'm ordering this I'm buying this
what if nobody gives a [ __ ] if you're
wired like I am when you know that okay
but stick with me stick with me I'm
gonna give you a couple scenarios if
you're wired like I am you love it
because you know eventually you're gonna
win and everybody's gonna look back on
it fine I know I'm in the minority Steph
it's first of all it comes down to self
awareness right it depends on how you
feel about yourself am i watching the
patterns of 14 year old teenagers who
are taking three minutes to seven
minutes to 15 minutes to take a selfie
then post it on Instagram then if they
don't get enough likes in the first 20
minutes take it down and start over Gary
I'm afraid of that well I'm afraid I'm
afraid of a lot of things no but I'm
afraid what are we doing to our young
people no no stop over we're not doing
jack [ __ ] this is what's happening
there's no real doing this is the
reality of human evolution like your if
this was 1961 and we were doing this
you'd be like Gary I'm worried about
Elvis shaking his hips what are we
teaching
I would never be worried about that yeah
so so this notion that you and I get to
say what we're worth this is happening
whether you or I like it this is what's
happening it's evolution
the end you're gonna be much more scared
about what's happening in this VR world
in 20 years than any of it you're gonna
wish for the day of selfies in 20 years
when people put on contact lenses and
don't come out for a month okay you know
what though Gary you're a dad you're a
dad you have two kids what are you gonna
do when your daughter is 14 and she's
locked in her room desperate to make
selfies and videos that people care
about when she walks out of room and
says no one likes me in this world I'm
gonna say Mischa our [ __ ] game
I'm gonna say to her I'm gonna I'm gonna
say to hurt Mischa if you're not making
stuff that people want to watch they're
not gonna watch darling that's what I'm
gonna say cuz that's the truth I'm gonna
say [ __ ] why I'm gonna served by
millions have to be how we define
ourselves I don't know tell me you're
putting yourself on TV I'm I might want
to do that but maybe other people don't
well I'm not telling [ __ ] Mischa she
has to do that but it's that's the way
we're going as a society what are you
talking about do you know many people
don't do that there are unlimited people
who don't do social media I met like
morning people under 30 in the last six
months that like a girl cutting my hair
and she's like 25 year old girl in San
Francisco during the Superbowl weekend
I'm like so what do you think about
snapchat she's like I don't have any
social media I'm like none she's like no
I'm like ever she's like nope I'm like
[ __ ] you know I was like you know and I
was like tell me more because I was like
who is this a trend that I need to
figure out you know like you know like
and so and so there is no this is what
we have to do there's no difference
between Misha doing that in her room
than her laying in her room in 1984
asking Lizzy and I for 3-way phone calls
so she could sit there and it's
nothing's changed it just gets
accelerated and what happens is we get
scared cuz we get old that's what
happens we get scared cuz we get old we
get scared of everything that we didn't
grow up with it's what human beings do
right that's all you're only 23 year
olds and 29 year olds in here that are
[ __ ] super comfortable with all this
[ __ ] when VR comes when they're 42 and
they have kids from that whoa this is
[ __ ] you know
that's what happens and so I don't I
know that it's evolution I'm very
comfortable in it I'll always be
comfortable with it I have a six and a
three-year-old now nothing's changed on
my point of view and guess what when
something bad happens my point of view
will still not change I'll be sad that a
micro event happened and the data then
going our way I'll be sad that Misha is
crying or Xander got hurt I'll be sad
but it's not gonna make me say well now
let's shut down evolution we're gonna
shut down evolution this is what's gonna
happen
pelion you can help shape it I don't
know about that I think that people
grossly overestimate their ability to
shape it how important is it to brand
yourself for everyone out there who's an
entrepreneur they're starting a business
how important is it to tied their name
their face to that business to make it a
success it's only because it's only
important if they're good at it so for
example you know this there's unlimited
amounts of companies that are successful
that nobody's ever heard of the CEO
there's unlimited of people that are
worth billions of dollars that nobody's
ever heard of right so it comes down to
knowing oneself right so for me this is
very important because of a couple
things I think I'm good at it there's
another important thing I really
genuinely like it I like looking out
there and saying chef and Eric I'd like
to get to know people I know them I like
it I like people so I put myself in the
best position to succeed
I like people the social network world
is about people interactions it was
gonna naturally work for me however I
have tons of tons of startups and
founders who asked me every day they
take my money they want my advice and
they're they're not into people and they
don't want to put themselves out there
and they're very happy to put their head
down and build a good product but our
consumers demanding no that day I use
uber as an example hold on
no I don't know nobody here gives a [ __ ]
that Perry Chen is fairly quiet if they
like Kickstarter they're gonna use it
but here's where you're wrong okay
people give a [ __ ] about uber and Travis
people won't hold on a second I'm not
wrong that's just another [ __ ]
different example
except I'm not Wong don't gimme no but
if you say peep I don't give a [ __ ] they
do I do not just nobody here cares about
isn't even I don't think night is still
I don't even know the CEO of Nike mark
Parker great
why didn't you told me I'll give you the
[ __ ] Jets right now I couldn't have
answered that and I don't give a [ __ ]
about him or his life or a selfie that's
why he's [ __ ] ok then it's just
another option ok ok I explained the
uber phenomenon to me hold on how there
are people who put who criticized uber
and their management and their founder
and don't think get sawed it's just a
great black car that shows up at my
house and it's cheaper than a cab
instead that's those are the same people
that move to Canada when Bush and Obama
got elected ah okay there you go so many
people here want to talk about if they
even cared that they were mad at uber
for whatever current headline-grabbing
thing that somebody wants to write
because it's good for business insider
right there traffic it's good to say
something but then they get into an uber
40 minutes later they go they literally
go and they do silly human beings are an
out that's right why don't you two get
well I understand listen I know you're
leading I'm just yes I'm just following
you tell me where to go next
I mean you know Gary's a follower right
uh it's nothing I I don't think people
care I think people care about their
things and if they're a Yenta and they
love that [ __ ] that may care you know
cares and has always cared your mother
you said earlier that your mother
complimented you five hundred times a
day she did for me every day my whole
entire life my mom calls me on the phone
and says you could do anything and then
hangs up there's somebody in the
audience who's a stay-at-home mom she
wants to be that kind of inspiration yes
what does she do what did your mom say
my mom balanced accentuating my
strengths while letting know that my
weaknesses were not completely
acceptable to punt but kinda right one
more time
yep what she did was every time I made a
thousand dollars in a baseball card show
that's unbelievable do you know many
people can't even do that
like as grown-ups or as grown you know
and that's that's what she would say you
know or you know or whatever she would
say I mean sleaze [ __ ] like you know
like she liked the way I swung my wiffle
ball bat you know like it could be
anything like I skipped well you know on
the way to the park like she would go
there but when I would get f's
or do something that wasn't right she
would make me understand there should be
consequences for that she would punish
me even though I mean my mom would
punish me even as a junior in high
school for FS on my report card did you
get a lot of F's unlimited that's okay
there's not unlimited s-step I've one
report card I've been actually trying to
hit up north hundred in high school to
give me access to my report card cuz I
want to throw it on throat throwback
Thursday I think they have it they don't
yeah I've been trying to get it because
literally I only got these in apps I
would get a B in history I'd get a name
Jim and I would get FS or DS for
everything li cuz I never hope from the
first day of high school until the last
day I never opened a single book once
ever I never did one piece of homework
in my entire four years of iy because I
knew who I was
and I knew that they were gonna push me
through and that I needed the time to
hone my skills on my future and not
figure out where Saturn was
so so so so when I got home as a
freshman in high school and the new
Beckett baseball card guide would come
out I would lay in bed for six hours and
memorize the prices on everything
because pretty cell phones and
information when I'd go to the baseball
card show on Friday if I had all the
prices memorized that was an advantage
over the other people that didn't seeing
that that's your story is that your
journey is the or is that a path you
recommend for others what are you gonna
say to your kids when they're in the
ninth grade they're going to New York
City's finest
and they say I'm not opening a book I'm
gonna say if you have the chops to be an
entrepreneur
let's [ __ ] start right now but if not
you need to explain to mommy and daddy
what the [ __ ] you're thinking
do you think this is the year we've been
saying for the last few years content is
king content is king and there's so much
content at this point do you think we're
coming to a point in time where we're
actually gonna start to really curate
and really separate and say a lot of
this is noise here's the high value
product I think we do that every day and
have done it for every day of our
existence so what I mean by that I mean
we choose this weekend to watch entire
seasons of house of cards because we
decide that's good content for us and
instead of watching something else
you're reading something else we chose
that and I think the marketplace has
always been the marketplace and so I
think that's been happening all along
that's what happens every day there's
been more than enough content to fill
our days for much longer than the
Internet's been around once capable 1 to
36 channels with the amount of
newspapers and books that were produced
we've been picking and choosing what's
good every day these people chose that
this was the best of use of their time
that this is what they wanted to do on a
late Sunday afternoon I'm humbled by
that because Sunday's are tough that's
family time this that any other thing we
do it every single day of our lives and
what I love is there's even more content
now right there's just so much right I
know when I do dailyvee that's a sick
that's a sitcom that's a 20 30 minute
video that they're gonna watch instead
of watching something else and I think
that will always go on forever when you
do daily ving you look back on it other
days where you say oh that was garbage
or do you think it's all great I think
it's all great
really sure because I think it's all
true
right like this doesn't mean it's great
sure does I actually for me that's what
that's that's what I want to make sure
one of the things I'm most proud of is
that d-roc will always be able to tell
somebody over a drink
25 years from now that like yeah he
didn't tell me to do anything like I
like that I stay away from it he does it
and he does it well walk us through in
case people don't know what that is I do
a daily blog I'm on that base yep yeah I
get it episode 19 is where we're at
right now it's a 13 to 30 minutes show
that we put out you know it's called
daily because d-roc and I had big eyes
that we were gonna do a five days a week
but he's a he's he's unbelief unfor me
to watch what's happening with daily me
cuz he's getting a lot of accolades a
lot of credit cuz not only is he filming
he's editing and he's working his face
off I mean he's literally think about
this I talked about how hardcore I am I
literally he follows me for 15 hours and
then sometimes he'll literally then go
to the office and start editing so like
it's really great for me to see him get
his due and people are really talking
about his talents in the comments and
like so somebody the other day I'm
saying oh [ __ ] we need Stefan to follow
d-roc who follows Gary cuz I want daily
d-roc you know and so um it's really
cool to watch it but I feel great about
it
because I've never felt felt such a
feedback loop on anything I've ever done
like dailyvee because people that know
me well are like [ __ ] man I didn't
realize you really worked that hard and
I have to be honest with you we only
started dailyvee because I wanted to
note make sure everybody knew that I was
working harder than them it came from a
very dark place
Gary everybody in this room loves you
they want you to love them what quality
I don't want to use the word genius I
know we're in the genius dome what
quality do you see in people that you
gravitate towards what do you love
optimism
I love optimism you know I hate cynicism
like I love like I want to build an
empire on good
like I hate Steve Jobs as narrative he
changed the world he's unbelievable but
like he didn't make people happy that
worked for him I don't like that I don't
want to do that my biggest ambition if I
can pull off what I'm gonna pull off
here is to build a pair you are pulling
it off yeah I know but I got but I'm a
ways to go I am pulling it off but
anything can happen
like I don't I truly live Steph in a
world where I'm only as good as my last
at-bat like I'm not interested in eating
you know like consuming my hyperbole or
reading my headlines I like them they
make me feel good but I'm not confused
by them I've got a long way to go to
pull off what I really want to pull off
which is to become a standard of
building an empire a professional
business empire on doing good stuff not
on I was tough on you because I wanted
to get the best work out of you I don't
like that I want to win with honey over
vinegar I like that I like happiness
optimism okay I know I want to finish
optimism that is loaded with
practicality so many of you in here and
I know you you're loaded with optimism
without practicality you wish your
something without really understanding
who you actually are
and in that wishing you change your
behavior and you make yourself
vulnerable for upside and so I'm I'm
good at a couple things and if you
notice the reason the reason I have so
much bravado and confidence is I mainly
talk about my stuff look I've been on
your show and you know when it's subject
matters when I'm like part of it and I
gotta say stuff you know if it's subject
matters I don't know I can be pretty
like you know I'll get out of there
right like I I don't want it I don't
want to talk about you know I'm doing
Tuesday night I'll be the bomb in full
promotion Tuesday night I'll be on CNN
right so I'll be with Don Lemon and I
mean what are we gonna talk about we're
talking about politics I'm gonna [ __ ]
dance yeah like you know because I don't
cuz I'm a headline reader I have not
even begun to really pay attention to
the presidential hero yeah and I vote
I'm very proud of way that I vote I
voted very consistently on both sides of
the aisle and that's because I make it
practical not emotional there'll be two
candidates and I'm gonna pick the one
that I think I want to be there and I'm
not gonna get crippled by oh I live in a
state where it doesn't matter like I'm
gonna do my thing I'm gonna make my
decision I'm gonna move on there's one
thing you didn't talk about that I want
you to okay you talked about being
optimistic yes and you want to create an
empire you want to do with you know
through love and that's hate yes but I
think you also do it with a level of
brutal honesty yes and that's something
that in the in the PC hyper human
resource rapt world that we're living in
in a professional environment many
criticisms is honesty has sort of been
taken out of the equation because we're
forced yes to be so super sensitive yes
you're not super sensitive not in this
subject matter um mainly because I'm
selfish and what I mean by that is I
want to be historically correct and if
I'm not honest I won't be and that's it
I'm telling you right now this is where
I balance my good is so often so
self-serving but it could manifests in
such a way if you're honest about I
agree the only fundamental reason that I
try to spit my honest answer to every
question is I have a very good long
track record of being right and I want
to continue that and I think there's
enormous leverage in it and so if I
answer honestly and it becomes true it
really helps me right and I want to
continue to do that well you're doing it
care we are out of time thank you
thanks for coming thank you
focus we are done with this portion of
the program but it would not be a Gary
the event without a book signing outside
as well as don't you want a selfie with
this are you gonna get all those
followers Gary this is the end of my
portion thank you there's an honor to be
here with you please stay get your book
get it saw and get a picture with Gary
thank you